today for our daily cancellation we are
canceling the dreaded
the stupid the pointless pay it forward
drive-through chains now if you aren't
familiar with this thoroughly first
world phenomenon here's a story about
the latest one to pop up from cnn uh
there's a bunch of stories about this
let yesterday but this the cnn says what
started as a random act of kindness from
one man
paying the paying for the car behind him
in a dairy queen drive-thru
resulted in over 900 cars also taking
part in the pay it forward chain at a
drive-through in brainerd minnesota over
100 miles north of minneapolis people
stepped up in a small way to show one
another that they care
tina jensen the store manager one of the
two dairy queens in town told cnn
a man came by the drive-through window
on thursday and asked if he could pay
for his meal and for the car behind him
jensen told her cashier this tends to
happen once in a while but at most it
lasts for 15 or 20 cars of
cars and fizzles out this time the chain
continued for two and a half days
with over 900 cars participating raking
in 10 000
in sales when the next customer came to
the fast food chains window
jensen explained what the man in front
of them had done and the act of kindness
continued to multiply
jensen said there's all different types
of ways to help people i think this
touched a lot of people that we didn't
even know it touched deeper than we know
and you don't know what's going on in a
person's life when the chain closed
for the night on thursday one car left
ten dollars to begin the chain
back up on friday morning and then the
same thing happened on friday night and
it began on saturday morning
okay so that's how it works somebody
pays for the meal of the person behind
them in line then that person pays for
the person behind them
and on and on it goes but do you know
who the real hero in this story is
not the first person to pay for the next
person no the real hero is whoever broke
the chain
and simply accepted the charity from the
person in front and drove away
leaving the person behind them to pay
for their own damned fudge sundae
all of the people in between the first
guy who may have been well
intentioned but should have thought more
about the consequences of his actions
and the last guy who had the courage to
end the whole charade everybody else
these were just sheep they weren't
performing acts of kindness this wasn't
charity they did it because they were
too embarrassed and felt too much social
pressure
not to do it if it's charity at all it's
coerced charity and not for a meaningful
cause either
the people in the drive-thru line have
disposable income that they were already
planning to spend
on the same kind of junk that you're
buying they don't need your money
really this kind of charity if it is
charity at all again is similar to the
sort of charity that you perform
when you're checking out of the grocery
store and the cashier asks if you want
to round up
and donate your change to you know
orphaned
sea otters or whatever the only reason
you say yes is because you'd feel like a
cheap ass refusing to give your 27 cents
to the sea otters
it's not something that comes from the
kindness of your heart
if you wanted to help the sea otters on
your own time you would
right now all you want to do is pay for
your carton of eggs and your packets of
paper towels and leave
the grocery store is taking advantage of
your sense of shame
to build another few cents out of you
another few cents of which they will
surely take a cut by the way
but while the grocery store charity
gambit is a calculated ploy to take
advantage of people who don't have the
spine to say no
the pay it forward chain is more of a
case of collective insanity
everyone is doing it but nobody knows
why
if you want to understand how crazy it
is imagine how it would come across
if you took you know take take the fast
food
and the cars out of the equation okay
now imagine you're standing in a long
line of people
uh waiting for something and the guy in
front turns to you
gives you five dollars out of his wallet
and then suggests
that you turn around and give the person
behind you some money out of your wallet
and on and on and on
now you're all just passing money
backwards for absolutely no reason
nobody wants to be doing it or knows why
they're doing it
but it continues until some free thinker
accepts the cash from the person in
front
and says hey thanks for the money puts
it in their pocket and gives nothing to
the person behind
that person again is the admirable
character in this
strange saga now if i sound like i'm
speaking from a
place of personal trauma when i talk
about this that's because i
am i used to live near starbucks where
this would happen
frequently i was duped by it i'm ashamed
to admit
one time and one time only i pulled up
to the window
to pay for my one single coffee for 265
and the girl at the window told me that
the bill had been paid by the guy in
front
then she informed me that they were
doing this pay it forward thing where
each person pays for the one behind
and she asked me if i wanted to
participate and told me that you know
they kept the chain going for
50 cars so far or however many it was
so i said uh yeah okay
sure and then she said okay that'll be
43.50
i had just traded in my 2 coffee for a
whole
suv load of lattes and frappuccinos and
god only knows what else
it was the worst deal in history as
trump might have said if you'd saw it
so i drove away broken
confused my coffee now tinged with a
taste of betrayal
and i resolved then to never allow
myself to be shamed into empty gestures
of pointless charity
and from then on whenever someone in
front paid for my drink i said oh great
i accepted the free coffee drove away
with no remorse
in fact proud that i had saved others
from this farce
and even and you know when the cashier
asks me now about the sea otters i say
no thank you i don't want to help him
in fact the sea otters can go to hell
and i walk away feeling fine
though wondering if i was a little
harsher towards the sea otters than
necessary
anyway this is why the pay it forward
drive-through lines
are canceled forever and always
by the way i must also acknowledge my
own debt for the cancellation today this
was inspired by amanda prestigiacomo a
writer for the daily wire
who spoke out against this yesterday the
paid forward lines on twitter
got me thinking about this so she is the
opposite of cancelled but everybody else
in that 900 person chain in minnesota
is unfortunately cancelled well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt
walsh show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on
all of our future content